I'm like 85% straight I feel pretty
confident saying that you know 85% 90%
straight still consider myself straight
one we brought together seven straight
women I am straight I am straight I am
straight I am straight I'm straight I am
straight I am straight one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives he or she wins the entire prize
oh my gosh what are you guys listening
to like what music all of the Taylor
Swift lover album Taylor Swift yeah I'm
up Taylor to it it's popping out to
listen so that was sick earlier so much
was happening at once there was a lot of
people talking a lot of people jumping
in and interjecting and wasn't doing
your spare time did your onion I take
pictures I work I cook I travel a lot
like I feel like me my husband have like
a ton of stuff to do
where's the last place everyone travel
Japan actually oh my gosh where did you
go Kyoto Tokyo Kyoto Osaka I'm matter
how do yoga I just told myself I'm gonna
vote for the prettiest earliest one that
I see even though we only had a minute
other people were speaking up more and
she was just pretty quiet I thought that
other people would vote for her and
better her than me y'all found out the
girl in the crop top what literally what
I am so confused right now I don't know
it just happened I feel like she got
voted out because like all the girls
were low-key jealous that she was like
so pretty
can I see all your nails you can't you
have long nails if you're a lesbian
wink wink that didn't really work
because all the girls had really nice
long pretty nails except for me
[Music]
okay I'm gonna be honest there was a
time like I felt like mmm maybe like in
my brainwash too like guys and then I
tried to like look at a girl and then I
was like no I think that we can all
appreciate beautiful women like you're
not like zendaya like no one's gonna
deny you know what I mean I've never
like dated a woman but I mean I guess
like if I was single and it was like
time like I wouldn't I don't know yeah
like I don't know if it was a different
time in my life like it's 2019 so I feel
like people are a lot more open like I
finally viewed sexuality as kind of like
on a spectrum people that I've been
sexually attracted to have been men so
but that doesn't mean that it's
impossible for me to be yes actually
attracted to women I'm like 85% straight
I think I'm 85% straight it's an
interesting phrase I feel pretty
confident saying that you know 85% 90%
straight still consider myself straight
woman you know if you slip you slide
essentially like you know you don't want
to kind of give anything like that's the
way but the things that she embodies
they what's what am I trying to say why
didn't your last relationship work out
yeah I went to kind of an had sex with
four girls okay not bad no I was gone
for a literally yeah my most recent ex
we were actually best friends for like
five or six years and the whole time I
thought she was gay so when he finally
told me that he liked me because I was
actually talking to one of his friends
he was like hey man I feel kind of
backstab right now I really like you I
was like but you're not
[Laughter]
the girl next to me Gabi kind of winked
at me and did like oh hey do what I do
and like her okay cool felt like I was
the most stereotypical like lesbian
looking person I mean in my day I think
I trust you guys I'm just saying
I think I already voted out them all and
I'm not just saying that because I'm a
mole I'm not as confident I don't know
thank you my finger got fat and so I
took it off because it was cutting off
my circulation look at you I think
mentioning the marriage thing but she
didn't have a ring so I'm was like okay
maybe like she was like but I have a tan
line it's like okay well I have a tan
line for like a watched how wait how did
you in her meet we met in college he was
my apartment like neighbors best friend
I saw the ring and she was talking about
her husband and I just thought she could
be just switching out husband for wife
how did you recording studio we both do
music in what does he play he plays
guitar I play guitar and piano and I
sing and he plays guitar we played jazzy
stuff we play weddings all the time we
do jazzy Drake covers sent me Brazil
Nathan ranch I love you Oh night works
for the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department I don't know if they were us
to include that she was really talkative
so I feel like in that sense like
someone who's I'm trying to
overcompensate for something would be
more of a chatterbox just kind of picked
her because her life seemed like really
perfect and wonderful and that for sure
you know her husband could have just
been you know a white guy is oh my god
[Music]
again look back good to be back
there's no way they're gonna vote me in
and then vote me back out again like I'm
good okay who voted her back in I did
lose her virginity
I don't eat Karen he's my watch this but
say my mom knows I told her about it
because like I had nightmares afterwards
Oh like we were very I grew up very
religiously so like it was you know I
wasn't married yet so yeah well if it's
one of you guys I will truly be shocked
very surprised and your acting skills uh
Maddie was just kind of the last straw
like oh I trust her but don't know if I
trust her it was hurtful to be so close
to the end did not make it
who was it that I realized I was lesbian
at 12 years old I was bullied
mercilessly throughout middle school in
high school for being gay I went through
phases where I shaved my head I went
through phases where I dressed super
girly just trying to figure out who I
was and Hailey revealed herself to be
them all I was completely shocked I had
not expected it how did you guys guess
it I'm so just you
I do fight for lipstick lesbian
representation look at my Instagram this
is literally my every day seeing girls
that like actually believe that I'm gay
is like really cool without me having to
explain myself
yeah it's 2019 and people just don't fit
into a box anymore hey guys thanks for
watching odd man out just a reminder we
just dropped collection three of human
good pre-orders are ending soon yes and
also ten percent of all profits go back
to amazing human beings all around the
world who are standing for empathy and
human good who we're collecting your
stories of who we can give back to so
check out the link in the description
box and the pin comment and thanks as
always for watching yeah see you next
time bye